oh yeah
the excited yeah to hoof
I played hoops in college you do yeah
I've been coming down here for some time
and I knew it was somebody that I need
to meet the man that's next to the man
that's next to the man to plug himself
mister Nevada explain your profession to
the people I have a PhD in VIP so you
basically know how to treat the people
that's right so how did you know that
you had this specific gift my father had
a casino since I was three years old he
had his okis in his own casino to
so he's the original owner and founder
of the stratosphere tower that we were
mandated to live within five minute
drive of the property so I always lived
in there but you could imagine I'm
riding my bike go-kart playing football
basketball
we had Dover mix I'm running them
through this trip it all was true on the
street by the strip the bar continues to
get raised in Vegas like like never
before the explosion and development
it's a really fun place to be we have
people like you coming in performing
goods you know and Nevada jury owner it
is it's my given name so what I mean
tell me about this PhD so last week we
had a group of CEOs that came in not big
club people but wanted to figure out how
do we get behind the scenes team right
and did a four stop culinary tour
helicopter trip cocktail reception in
the room next day had their meetings in
the room escaped room team-building over
to the Palms for the new restaurant
speaker that talks about the secrets of
casino marketing and how to whale hunt
out a whale really yeah it was it was it
was it was a lot of fun for them the
next day chef's table
joël Robuchon only three-star Michelin
rated restaurant in Vegas meeting the
chef in the kitchen private room and
this is all-inclusive
this is all-inclusive so one of the cool
ones that we did not too long ago was we
did a million-dollar bachelor party so
we had 40 people that flew in tandem
jets had to have their Hugh Hefner
moment hundred thousand at the club 250
thousand at the pool party type of deal
you know set dinners all they had to do
was show up and have a good time
everything else was taken care of there
already later we had it laid out dough
will be your fee in all the dish we
probably put about 10% on top of what
the people would pay anyway so you're
like a wedding planner on steroids for
the VIP exactly yes my goal is
for the guests to feel like they own the
place when they're inside the place
you're - that people know them when they
come in change how you're doing
wait - have you asked you up the people
see this they're gonna be trying to call
you with a whole bunch of [ __ ]
you're trying to waste your time let's
be honest what's the minimum that you
you move for entry-level would be a 10k
budget we'd get you a baby baller
package for that baby you know and we go
all the way up from there
sky's the limit looking birds wouldn't
get me I appreciate it I wanted to bring
in my dad's old pinkie ring he had 20
carats on the pinkie in the eighties
today is my lucky day
ah you know this is this is for the
vault no I thought it was a prison
rest in peace department he put some DNA
out here